San Diego has started building a border
wall San Diego started building a border
wall yeah not to stop immigrants but to
keep the LA Chargers from coming back
here's a crazy story in the news the
other day in Australia a wedding took
place inside a Costco a wedding in it a
wedding inside a Costco yeah
yeah because it was a Costco the groom
came home with 12 brides yeah oh you're
gonna love this one in China in China
for the first time ever a robot
performed dental surgery without human
assistance and that amazing a robot
without assistance yeah everyone was
excited until they remembered that the
robot was just supposed to vacuum the
living room now is the problem
[Applause]
and bring back those wisdom teeth
researchers say they may have figured
out how the ancient Egyptians built the
Great Pyramids of Giza yeah yeah what
they haven't figured out is how the
ancient Egyptians got Mexico to pay for
it and I gotta mention this story in
Britain a group of hikers had to be
rescued from the country's highest peak
because they were too stoned to walk
yeah yeah yeah the hikers were thousands
of feet high and then they started
climbing the mountain so
[Applause]
you